if you look at every u.s recession well
since world war ii
you'll see two things always happen the
gdp the measure of economic output goes
down and unemployment goes up
for most americans when do you feel a
recession
it's when you're still worrying about
your job
now let's look at today
the gdp is going down
even the head of the federal reserve
says a recession is certainly a
possibility but the unemployment rate
it's actually falling more people are
getting jobs not losing them
we don't know if it's a recession what
we can say is that if it is one it's not
like anything we've ever seen before
here's why the reason the gdp and
unemployment are always together is
because they feed on each other when
businesses lay off workers people spend
less money which means businesses make
fewer profits and lay off workers
a recession can begin at any of these
points and in 2022 people could cut back
on spending just look at consumer
sentiment a measure that weighs how
people are feeling about the economy and
whether they plan to spend money soon
generally when people respond that they
feel more pessimistic
a recession follows and right now
they're feeling about as good as during
the great recession in 2008 thanks to
inflation
not a great sign for the gdp
if people are frustrated by high
inflation if they think inflation is
going to stick around for a while they
might pull back
convince companies to cut back and that
leads to worse outcomes for the economy
but businesses are in a different place
than past recessions this chart shows
the average corporate profit margin in
the past profits were in these single
digits leading into several recessions
including 2001. that was a business
driven recession where companies
invested they decided they had to cut
back in order to rebuild their profit
margins and that led us right into a
recession the bubble has now burst i
would not argue yet that we've seen the
bottom in nasdaq or in our tech index so
are we back in one of those cycles in
some ways it doesn't look like that
because profit margins are so high right
now not only are corporate profits in
double digits but the amount of cash
they have is close to four trillion
dollars analysts say that's a
significant downturn buffer they might
just decide they can weather this storm
and not lay off workers and not cut back
on investment and kind of get us to the
other end of this adjustment without a
big retrenchment that feeds on itself
and companies have an incentive to not
lose any workers because many are having
problems finding workers in the first
place it's a really unique time in the
job market the labor force participation
rate is as low as it's been in 40 years
and it isn't all due to the pandemic the
rate has been declining for a long time
you can see it in the unfilled job rates
too as more people leave the labor force
the more job positions become available
add in a pandemic and that's a lot of
jobs 11 million jobs are out there that
they just can't find people to fill now
to put that in perspective if you look
back at say 2019 when the economy was
considered to be exceptionally strong
unfilled job openings were 7 million so
like here we are talking about a
downturn in the economy and we have 4
million more jobs open than we had even
at the height of the last expansion so
you have to ask yourself question why is
that why is that happening one answer is
that there's generational change
happening in the economy we have
millions of baby boomers who are
retiring so they're just not as many
workers out there it's also been the
case that there's just been really
strong demand for goods and services in
part because of all the stimulus that
was pumped into the economy
during the pandemic and so that
combination of labor shortages and
strong demand
created this really robust job market
and it's this robust job market that can
make a 2022 recession if one develops so
different
after past recessions there was what was
called jobless recoveries where gdp
began to grow back but companies
continued to lay off workers right now
we're seeing a mirror image of that
where the economic output is contracting
and companies are still hiring it's what
i'm calling a jobful downturn but how
long could an economic downturn really
be job full this is unsustainable right
to have economic output contracting at a
time when companies are hiring so one of
two things has to happen either
the economy adjusts and companies start
expanding again or
the economy keeps contracting economic
output keeps contracting and companies
say whoa we're over our skis and we've
got to cut jobs one of those two things
is going to happen we just don't know
which of the two
no recession has ever looked exactly
like another and if there's a recession
in 2022 it won't look like anything
we've seen before either